[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
essendo una giornalista parto con un
fatto di cronaca
è la notte del 23 dicembre del 2021 un
mese e mezzo fa
il dottor sebastiani appena finito il
futuro di 12 ore 12 ore in sala
operatoria
quindi smetta il cane ci saluta la sua
assistente le dice di essere un po
stanco se ne va a casa si mette sotto le
coperte e non si sveglia più gli viene
un infarto nel sonno
ora non possiamo dire che sia morto per
quelle dodici ore di lavoro ma
sinceramente a me non sarebbe piaciuto
finire sotto il terre di un medico che
aveva già sulle spalle sette otto ore di
sale operatorie figuriamoci io scrivo
attaccata al computer la passate ore
vedo la madonna mi immagino quest'uomo
cosa poteva vedere dopo 12 ore
ecco però in italia il problema che non
ci sono alternative
o forse ci sono le alternative ma sono
quelle di non farsi operare come succede
all'ospedale di salerno dove ci sono 26
donne che dall'inizio di dicembre
attendono di estero peraltro al seno per
un carcinoma
ma la breast unit dell'ospedale ha
chiuso perché non ci sono medici e non
ci sono infermieri
potrei andare avanti tutta sera a
raccontarvi che cosa non funziona nella
sanità poi poter passare a raccontarvi
che cosa è una funzione nella scuola
e poi vi racconto anche cosa non
funzionano i trasporti e poi in altri
servizi essenziali
faccio prima a usare i dati dell'istat
ora sono tre righe e indicano il
finanziamento la percentuale di pil e
che lo stato investe nella sanità
nell'istruzione
e nei trasporti
vedete dal 2008 2009 la curva è andata
discendendo ciò vuol dire che i soldi
che lo stato mette per i servizi non
riescono a tenere il passo neppure
dell'inflazione sono sempre meno
ecco perché fanno possiamo dire schifo i
nostri servizi pubblici
ecco è questa slide
è stata elaborata da un professore
dell'università di modena si chiama
massimo baldini è stata elaborata per
l'espresso e ci dice che negli ultimi 20
anni i governi che si sono succeduti di
destra e di sinistra
hanno preferito dare piu soldi in tasca
agli italiani anziché
spenderli nei servizi
i soldi dati degli italiani sono
aumentati del 50 per cento quelli per i
servizi molto meno ci chiamiamo al 30 è
una domanda è anzi un altra cosa per
rendervi la cosa ancora più concreta
torniamo al servizio sanitario già stato
da nelle tasche degli italiani in cash e
in kind vuol dire i soldi diretti e in
servizi nella 150 euro a persona
però di questi 950 euro
360 servono per finanziare il servizio
sanitario banalmente per pagare gli
stipendi degli infermieri dei medici
per sistemare gli ospedali ma ci sono
pochissimi soldi per rimettere in
funzione i nostri ospedali mentre gli
altri 590 euro servono per dare questi
soldi in tasca agli italiani che
decidono di spenderli come come meglio
credono
per i farmaci per le cure ma se io sono
una persona povera me ne faccio poco di
questi 590 euro
preferisco avere un ospedale che
funziona nei pressi della mia casa
perché se sono povero dell'ospedale non
è di qualità sempre li devo andare sul
suo medico posso andare curarmi altrove
e quindi ho tantissime altre possibilità
benissimo allora la questione a perché i
governi fanno questa cosa perché
disinvestono pensano che la nostra i
nostri servizi siano la cenerentola per
due motivi primo è onorevole
e nobile ed è il fatto che dal 2008
l'italia non solo l'italia è andata
incontro una serie di crisi economiche
che sa che hanno impoverito moltissimo
le nostre famiglie e quindi lo stato
aveva la necessità di dare più soldi in
tasca la gente per permettere loro di
andare a fare la spesa
motivo nobile ma non è questo il motivo
perché l'ocse
come vedete alle mie spalle ci dice che
il 38 per cento di quelli solo di denaro
che lo stato restituisce nelle tasche
dei cittadini
esce al 20 per cento la popolazione più
ricca e solo il 13 per cento nelle
tasche della popolazione più povera ecco
considerate che questo dato già
considera il reddito di cittadinanza
veramente poca cosa
allora ci deve essere un altro motivo
mente i politici hanno capito che agli
italiani non piace pagare le tasse è sì
agli italiani piace andare in pensione
prima e chi non piacerebbe
capito per primo berlusconi nel 2008
quando si è presentato in campagna
elettorale ha detto vi ridurrà l'ici
allora si chiamava così la tassa sulla
prima casa gli italiani non è mai
piaciuta tassa sulla prima casa non
sempre odiata per un motivo perché in
italia ci sono tantissimi i possessori
di case quindi ci dà proprio fastidio
pagarla peccato che in europa l'italia e
malta sono gli unici due paesi che non
la pagano e anche nel resto del mondo ce
ne sono veramente pochi a sono me li
ricordo non sono pochi
comunque berlusconi ci costavano
effettivamente vince le elezioni
nel 2013 ci riprova il pd vince le
elezioni fatti toglie direttamente limo
sempre a tassa sulla prima casa e ha
solo cambiato nome ma non abbiamo più a
che fare col imo perfetto
funziona così bene il meccanismo che
l'anno successivo quando letta viene
sostituito da renzi renzi propone gli 80
euro in busta paga era la primavera del
2014 il mese successivo ci sono le
elezioni europee il pd prende il 40 per
cento di voti non è mai successo nella
storia del centrosinistra un successo
perfetto nel 2019
consci che il metodo funziona ci prova
governo giallo verde a ridosso delle
ulteriori elezioni europee e 5 stelle po
minore di cittadinanza e la lega propone
quota 100 quindi in pensione un po prima
effettivamente le elezioni europee per
tutte e due vanno molto bene ora
probabilmente ci sono anche degli altri
motivi che hanno permesso a questi
partiti di vincere le elezioni ma va
detto che italiani li votano quelli che
fanno queste affermazioni
perché i partiti hanno capito che quando
dicono queste cose riescono a stare
meglio attaccate alla poltrona è già
peccato che questi cinque scherzetti ci
sono costati 200 miliardi di euro fate
conto che il servizio sanitario in un
anno prende dallo stato per sopravvivere
20 miliardi di euro 200 miliardi ci
facevamo gli ospedali le scuole e
persino le strade probabilmente
ecco allora gli italiani hanno anche le
loro buone motivazioni
in questi giorni ricorre il trentennale
di mani pulite
probabilmente qualcuno si ricorda c'era
quando è successo qualcun altro no ecco
cos'era successo in mani pulite che gli
amministratori pubblici e i politici
sono stati trovati con le mani nella
marmellata a utilizzare i nostri i
nostri soldi pubblici anziché per le
scuole i servizi le case di riposo per
farsi gli affari propri e quindi li è
nata un po una grande disaffezione degli
italiani verso il bene pubblico e gli
italiani iniziato a dire pulici vabbè
facciamo che me li dai a me e ci penso
io perché tu non sei capace di gestire
lo stesso stato che sembra quasi aver
dichiarato bandiera bianca ok non siamo
capaci non so io stato non sono capaci
giusti tv di voi soldi ma questo è un
grosso problema
questo è un grosso problema che siamo a
un bambino che
nasce in un quartiere disagiato
ok l'unico modo per uscire da questa
condizione di povertà e la scuola
è sperare di fare un liceo un istituto
superiore che lo porti fuori dall idea
che nella vita non potrà essere altro
che uno spacciatore come suo cugino
una ragazza madre come la propria mamma
ok l'idea di dire ok se io farò con la
scuola magari però trovare un buon
lavoro per diventare un'insegnante solo
quella è la strada per uscire dal mondo
delle disuguaglianze in cui stiamo
finendo non vi ha convinto né faccio un
altro di esempio e vi prendo tutti in
considerazione in molti di voi allora
dal prossimo mese
vedrete un piccolo aumento in busta paga
perché hanno fatto una riforma
dell'irpef l'irpef è la tassa che
paghiamo sugli stipendi
mettiamo che prendete uno stipendio di
30mila euro in tasca vi rimangono 27
euro in più vi daranno 27 euro in più al
mese ci andate a mangiare una pizza
ottimo
ma il mese successivo un vostro vicino
parente si ammala di alzheimer
non esistono strutture per curare queste
persone le case di riposo le respingono
queste persone per sé una badante rumena
non la vuole questa persona perché sono
malattie che vanno curate 24 ore su 24
che come fate
utilizzate 27 euro per curarli
oppure avete un figlio finisce la
maternità
dovete tornare al lavoro però nel vostro
quartiere non c'è il nido pubblico c'è
solo quello privato e costo tra i 500 e
gli 800 euro alle 4 chiude e quindi
dovete prendervi anche la tata perché
voi finito il lavoro le sei ok
forse vi conviene restare a casa al
lavoro non andarci più al lavoro e poi
lingua da dire che le donne non lavorano
e grazie come si fa
comunque la questione è
uscita da questa situazione si esce
volendo più bene ai nostri beni pubblici
insistendo chiedendo alla politica al
vostro sindaco
è stato re locale al presidente dell'asl
disse di investire sulle vostre sui
vostri beni perché sono sempre i vostri
soldi perché è l'unico modo per ridurre
le disuguaglianze e a proposito di bene
pubblico io vorrei finire con un grazie
a chi ci lavora in questi beni pubblici
che in questi due anni ci hanno
dimostrato di essere l'unica ancora di
salvezza dal copit medici infermieri e
gli insegnanti che sono rimasti al loro
posto per farci vedere che esiste un
mondo diverso meno diseguale grazie a
tutto quello che è pubblico
grazie mille
una serata
[Applauso]